my name is Sheldon Clark I'm a junior at
Columbia College I'm majoring in
chemical physics and pre-med and I just
wanted to talk to you about my work
today on metal nanoparticles I've been
working in professor I simples lab in
the country Department for the past year
and a half and my work has been mainly
focused on metal nanoparticles and
studying them with really really
powerful lasers so just want to talk to
you a little bit about metal
nanoparticles first these metal
nanoparticles are really really
interesting the last several years not
only because they're really small these
are some transmission electron
microscope images all these
nanoparticles these ones are 60
nanometers and it's really hard to to
really see how small these are without
looking at that but you have to look at
the microscope to really appreciate that
but also these men of these metal
nanoparticles have what you call a
plasma on resonance so what happens is
when you hit a metal nanoparticle with
light since light is an electromagnetic
wave that's going to Ashley electrons up
and down and there's a specific
resonance frequency at which the metal
nanoparticle electrons oscillate just
like pushing a swing you get a resonance
frequency these this resonance frequency
here generates gigantic electric field
enhancements follow the light and that
leads to really strong scattering and
absorption of light which allows us to
use these metal nanoparticles for many
different purposes and applications some
of which are in photovoltaics got a
couple applications here whereas you
kind of put we kind of just lying a
solar panel of nanoparticles you do
greatly if it you really increase their
efficiency because the the it will
scatter the light into the solar panel
and trap it there or in cancer research
where you conjugate these nanoparticles
antibodies stick it into a body that
will stick to certain cancer cells then
you hit it with light and if it's at the
resonance frequency it's going to absorb
that light and generate heat now he can
be used to kill cells selectively so
that's a really big that's a really big
it's really big in research right now in
terms of the cancer research but what
we're interested in in the chemistry
department is studying the fundamental
properties of the nanoparticle surface
how that nano none of our service
interacts with other molecules and how
then Hansen actually works and the way
we do this is using a technique called
second harmonic generation this
technique you can only use with the
really really powerful laser so to just
give you an idea of how powerful these
lasers are essentially you put like a
piece of paper there it goes on fire
immediately if you if you focus that
laser you can get air to ionize you kind
of get this like fireball that's kind of
fixated in the air and all these
different colors because you turn the
gases the gas air into a plasma but um
with those really strong laser pulses
hitting these nanoparticles you can get
what you call a second-order
polarization so this is a polarization
of light as a result of light which is
electric field typically you're only
interested in the first order
polarization which accounts for all
scattering absorption of light but what
we're interested in second of my
generation is the second-order
polarization and because of some pretty
easy mathematical considerations that is
only allowed an interface so an
interface between two different media
basically that last is the selectively
study to service the nanoparticles and
by doing that we can study what the
electric field is at that surface and
how that enhances other molecules and
the experiment that we use to kind of
test this out and see what that
enhancement is how to quantify that is
comparing the shg signal of polystyrene
nanoparticle East irie nanoparticles and
its dye molecule malachite green versus
alloy Mel nanoparticles versus malachite
green polystyrene particles are
essentially insulator particles so they
have no plans on residence you can see
here that the signal goes up to 2000 as
this dye molecule absorbs onto the
surface due to shg signal but with the
metal nanoparticle that's a 1090 alloy
which is ten percent gold ninety percent
silver you get signal up to 80,000
counts for a second so that just kind of
like a simple way to quantify that
enhancement and explain that then
interaction that comes from the surface
and you can really enhance different dye
molecules that attach the nanoparticle
so we're hoping that all of these these
studies including all these
characterization studies understanding
the structure the nanoparticle this is
I'm just as understanding how
monodisperse they are what charge they
are all these different things in
chemistry and physics can kind of lead
to a greater understanding of what these
nanoparticles do how they actually work
in these different applications because
even though there's so many applications
it's not really well understood why it
happens and what the physical processes
that happen that allow but allow us to
use them so that's my work for the
moment I want to thank Lewis haber was
my mentor it's a postdoc working
izybelle lab and also dress horizon fell
in the chemistry department and thank
you